[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره افادت مصادر
محليه للجزيره بان الجيش التركي المتمركز
في قواعده بمناطق المعارضه الشماليه
وغربيه سوريه استهدفا مواقع لما تعرف
بقواته سوريا الديمقراطيه في ريف الحسكه
كما تعرضت مواقع هذه القوات لقصف بالاسلحه
الثقيله والمدفعيه التركيه الشمال الرقه
وريف عين العرب عين الحدود السوريه
التركيه
اكدت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان انقر تدرس
مقترحات قدمها وفد روسيا تقضي بانسحاب
مقاتلين ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مع اسلحتهم من عين العرب ومن بيشه واضافت
المصادر للجزيره
ما تعرف في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على
هذا المقترح شريطه ضمان عدم حصول اجتياح
تركي
توصلت واشنطن موسكو الى صفقه لتبادل
السجناء تم بمقتضها الافراج عن لاعبه
السله الامريكيه بريتنير التي كانت محتجزه
في روسيا واطلاقه سراح رجل الاعمال
الروسيه فيكتور
وصلبوت الى روسيا بعدما امضى 10 سنوات في
السجون الامريكيه من اصل حكم مدته 25 عاما
بعد اذنته بتهم التامر لقتل مواطننا
امريكيين وتصدير اسلحه مضاده للطائرات
ودعم منظمات ارهابيه
واظهرت صور لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه
بريتشنر بعد اطلاق سراحها وكان تجننر تقضي
حكم الروسيا بالسجن تسع سنوات بتهمه حيازه
زيت الحشيش امضت منه اقل من عام
قال الرئيس الامريكي
عملت منذ فتره طويله من اجلها الافراج عن
جرينر واوضح ان الاداره الحاليه تعد
بالعمل على اطلاق مزيد من السجناء في
روسيا ومنهم الامريكي الاخر
بولاند الذي لا يزال محتجازا في روسيا
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارنجا
بيير ان التبادل السجناء بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لن يغير شيئا في التزام
واشنطن تجاه الشعب الاوكراني وموقفها من
الحرب
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه انها تفاوضت معه
واشنط لضمان الافراج عن رجل الاعمال
الروسيه فيكتور بوت منذ مده طويله وان
الولايات المتحده في البدايه رفضت الحوار
فيما يتعلق بقضيته في اي عمليه تبادل
قال رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه
الالمانيه
ان بلاده وجهت ضربه قويه لتنظيم مواطن
الرايخ وكشف ان اعضاء من التنظيم جاءوا من
الجيش الالماني ويمتلكون مهارات القوات
الخاصه فضلا عن امتلاكههم اسلحه من
مخزورات الجيش
وقد دهمت الشرطه الالمانيه 150 موقعا
جديدا ويتوقع ان تشنا موجه اعتقالات جديده